he's entering his 20th year as a
national football league head coach year
20 entering year 6 with the Kansas City
Chiefs he is Andy Reed how are you coach
I'm doing good rich yes I'm very good
know well you know how do you want to
handle this in the offseason because
normally it starts where you give an
injury report and then tell me the time
is mine how do you want to how do you
want to work this here listen I'm on
your show the times always yours okay
all right very good because I guess
there's there is no injury report right
now right no injuries healthy as you can
be right now okay you're 20 as an H C in
the NFL coach how does that hit you yeah
you know what you make me feel old but
uh it's uh it's a blessing I love every
minute of it rich I'm as excited today
as I was the first year I was a head
coach I mean I love doing what I'm doing
feel very honored to be able to do it
and do it for the Chiefs which is a
great organization as you know so very
fortunate so how players change in the
20 years yeah I think it's technology I
think that's about it but it's the same
thing once you get it on the grass
there's there are no cell phones or
smartwatches or you know they're all
yours and and all they want to do is
work they don't care how much money they
make they don't you know how much money
you make they don't care they just want
to they want to win and find a way to do
it and work and I can appreciate that I
mean that's a it's kind of a fun fun
atmosphere that the other people don't
get to see they think you're coaching
all these rich guys and they won't they
do whatever they want to do but that's
not that's not how they operate so
you're just saying technology is pretty
much the only difference between players
in 1999 when you walk through the door
and Philadelphia is a head coach and
when you're gonna walk through the door
in Kansas City for another playing
season in a couple of months well I
think yes no technology can expand
horizons so they maybe they're a little
bit wiser in some areas maybe they're
exposed to more things so technology can
open up doors off the field and whatever
direction you want to go in a positive
way or a negative way that maybe the
players didn't have back in the back in
that time
when you're on the grass it's it's the
same guy and I appreciate that part and
you all have changed a little bit well I
mean in terms in terms of that I guess
the rules what what what do you think of
this new catch rule and you do you think
the NFL's figured it out yeah listen I I
listen to John Harbaugh talk about it
probably three four years ago and he did
a big study on it and at the time it was
touching three feet and down and you
know having three ticks and and then
that was a catch and so anything passed
and I was and he kind of simplified it
down to that so and then it's kind of
expanded from there but I think the
foundation of it started there people
started looking at it and it made sense
and and so that's kind of where we're at
I kind of like it and I think it'll
clear up some things well I do too the
thing that I think still needs some
clearing up though in all honesty is the
new I don't even think think it's fair
to call it a targeting rule but the fact
that you are not allowed to lower your
helmet make contact and I'm wondering if
that still means a quarterback on a
sneak if that means an offensive lineman
already down the field blocking ten
yards for a runner that's already zipped
by and and now suddenly plays that we
think are our big plays in the NFL
suddenly there's a flag on the field and
we didn't even see this happen and I
think fans are gonna go crazy about that
sort of thing what what do you as a
coach know about this rule about
lowering your helmet so far mid-may yeah
so I don't think it'll be quite that
drastic for those type of situations I
think what you're looking at is those
egregious hits those ones that they're
trying to get rid of those that hurt the
player himself that's doing them and
then also can cause damage to another
player so I think that's really where
we're at and then the officials will
take care of they have a good feel the
coaches and the officials all met along
with the competition committee it was
kind of a neat deal and so they've come
up with this thing together things that
can be coached things that can be
officiated and in listen
the head going to be a part of that yeah
I mean it's a it's a it's a it's an
issue but the the Commissioner says he's
been in it's tried to you know clean
this game up so it can be as safe as
possible for a contact sport so and
that's my hat goes off to them for that
it's not an easy thing and and you're
dealing with a lot of different
personalities here not only within the
NFL but also fans so I think he's done a
heck of a job with it Andy Reid here on
the Rich Eisen show what rule would you
like to see changed that hasn't been
changed if anything yeah I'm always
griping and this is coach talk now so I
know we're all we always want more time
to coach and so any restriction that you
have on that you go doc GaN can I get
some more time but we work it out
coaches do that we're flexible although
my hamstrings are tighter than yours
you'd beat me in the 40 I'm done yet I
wouldn't be able to stay with but that
the the fact that we're always looking
for more time but that's what you know
that's that's how this thing works it's
a give-and-take we understand it and and
so we work with what we have when we go
so what where does Patrick mahomes stand
right now now that again you're gonna be
able to get him you've gotten them back
in an offseason workout program now
officially how ready is he week one this
year Andy yeah so yeah we start off with
the Chargers so it's a that's a big game
obviously for us just because the
division rival rate so on so it's a he
he's done a heck of a job he was very
fortunate to be in that room with Alex
Smith I mean I can't say that enough
about you know that that opportunies kid
had to sit in there and and they learned
and there's no better pro than Alex but
I'm really excited to see how he does
with Washington I think Jay Gruden he
will be a great partnership there so but
with Patrick Patrick is is so smart and
his want to is so great and and that
part you appreciate he comes to work
every day and just wants to get better
he's always here he doesn't have a lot
of distractions and he wants to be the
best and so that's the way it goes about
his business now whether whether he gets
her or not who knows but he's got a
tremendous amount of talent and he's got
a great way about him and he loves
playing the game so I can hang with that
you know I'm okay with that
well we just we just came off of a
lengthy draft process evaluation process
where it was all about evaluating
quarterbacks I mean my gosh with all
those first-round quarterbacks and
grades with the quarterbacks of the
first-round grades this year last year
essentially you made an evaluation a
quarterback and your staff did with
Patrick mahomes you traded up for
mahomes with deshaun Watson also on the
board why did you now a year removed why
did you make that evaluation what did
what did you see in the homes that
you're excited to see this fall in that
regard well rich what we did we brought
all those top quarterbacks in and we
spent about six hours with each one of
them and and we just beat him up I mean
we wanted them to find out about it we
beat ourselves up with it - I mean if we
wanted to find out about them and and
them to find out about us and just to
see how things worked and listen what's
a kid now this a good football player so
there were tough decisions that we had
to make I thought the world of him what
a great attitude and you saw what he did
before he he got banged up there a
little bit but the sky's the limit for
him we just thought what we were doing
we we thought Patrick was the best fit
and rich you've been around this a long
time if you if you target one of those
guys and you go listen this is a guy
that we want to get in here you go get
them I mean that's what you do and so
the cost and you can evaluate the cost
all you want but you evaluate so much
that you end up with with no quarterback
and and Alex was getting up there just a
bit in age although I think you still
probably can play another four or five
years here so he keeps himself in great
shape but you know you've got to think
of those things in this business and so
that's the direction our personnel
department went we love the decision and
and I love
the players so I'm excited to coach him
and see how far we can grow together
here and that uh that's exciting that's
a very exciting thing I'm part of the
personnel department John Dorsey at the
time were you surprised now him in
Cleveland he went Baker Mayfield first
overall I wasn't at all I went at all
maker Memphis Baker Mayfield an Energy
giver I mean he's gonna come in and he's
gonna complain
I mean this isn't like the [ __ ] but he's
not the biggest gay but who cares if
they can play they can play and so
that's uh that's what john Felton and
more power to him he you know he's gonna
he's a good leader he's smart he can
sling the ball he's got good accuracy so
who knows I mean well you're shooting
fifty-fifty with these first-round picks
anyways I mean it's a it's a crapshoot
and you know that so you better go get
the guy you want you feel good about
your staff feels good about go get them
and then coach the heck out of them and
let's roll
couple more minutes left with Andy Reed
head coach of the Kansas City Chiefs so
many Chiefs fans are left scratching
their head coach over the trade of
Marcus Peters I mean when you get a
young kid in and you get a young kid who
has shown the ability to have some
shutdown talent those kids don't usually
get traded why why did that happen
best you can tell yeah so Mark's a heck
of a football player and and and he'll
do a good job for the Rams
you got to juggle a lot of things when
when you're doing this one of which is
capped and that's a that's a part of
this no matter how you cut it
it's a part of it and so I can't tell
you we're in the best camp situation in
the world and so that you take those
things into consideration a lot of
things behind the scenes they go into it
and and and so sometimes you have to
make tough decisions like that like he
left here he left here and in good
graces and everything so I mean I look
forward to we actually play him in
Mexico City so I look forward to that
and and and he'll do a great job there
but those are the tough decisions you
have to make in this business so it was
essentially a monetary thing down the
road that you needed to make a move well
that's part yeah that's part of it
that's a big part of it I mean Oh
things that you have to have to evaluate
there's a bunch of you know this there's
a bunch of different pieces that going
to make a big time decisions like that
and that was that was one of them wine
and then you know lastly somebody that
you're gonna see and you're gonna see
him twice a year in big-time battles
with big time division rivalry in the
history Jon Gruden I mean talk about
isn't this amazing how these things
happen that he's back he's in with the
Raiders again you're now at the Chiefs
one was the first time you met Jon
Gruden and you read yeah we were I
actually had here we were young kids we
were two of the youngest assistants and
the NFL at that time and it was a long
time ago in Green Bay we were together
on my conference staff there we were
with Mike that first year there and and
we were the young kids I mean we were
trying to figure it all out and and see
where we could go with this thing and
knowing that the average span for a
coach was about three years so we but
listen it worked out okay for us isn't
he's a heck of a football coach we're
still great friends and I look forward
to that challenge he'll have those guys
ready to go and that's what that's what
this is all about you want that ultimate
challenge and and and he'll get that
group to present that and that's
exciting
maybe we'll have Mariucci be the
honorary captain that game but he's had
you know he always shows that photograph
of you eatin that monster what this big
steak like the sixty sixty ounce or
something crazy like that some state
yeah mooch can eat he can eat yeah he's
a foodie and oh you think he says
different than that is wrong no it's
it's it really is watching Steve during
the season well he gets upset when we
say this cuz he thinks Gail is listening
and it gets in trouble with his wife so
yeah but we know the real story coach
thanks for the call I appreciate the
time
time is now back to yours thanks rich
you guys thanks for the call that's it
that's Andy Reid the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience